on en parle tout de suite avec nos deux
invités c'est le débat de ce soir et
nous sommes avec eux bruno m'égare ban
chefs de service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière et mélina dufrègne la
fléche l infirmière membres du collectif
sos soignants en danger bonsoir à tous
les deux et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france vous avez le
sentiment d'être pointé du doigt
aujourd'hui mélina dufresne oui tout à
fait je pense qu'on a quand même été là
quand on a besoin nous sommes évidemment
les premières lignes et puis dans là de
toute façon je pense que ce débat et et
lanoraie n'a pas lieu d'être
je sais je crois pas que la vaccination
des soignants a changé le cours de
l'épidémie et de la rendre obligatoire
encore mois comment est-ce qu'on répond
à cette impression d'être un stigmatiser
bruno m'égare ban tout en protégeant
aussi de la population alors que le coe
vide est considérée aujourd'hui comme
une maladie nosocomiale
écoutez moi je ne ressens pas du tout
l'obligation vaccinale comme une
stigmatisation
au contraire c'est plutôt une
reconnaissance de notre rôle de notre
mission de nos devoirs
nous sommes au front nous devons soigner
les patients les plus fragiles
immunodéprimées nous ne devons pas
évidemment leur transmettre une maladie
potentiellement grave aux mortels le
fait de nous mettre face à nos
responsabilités
c'est au contraire plutôt très
honorifique salle où ça montre
évidemment l'importance de notre rôle et
ça va permettre évidemment que nous
servions de dynamique à la vaccination
dans le pays mais n'a dufresne quel
retour est ce que vous avez de vos
collègues sur la vaccination quel
argument est ce qu'il vous donne pour
expliquer qu'ils ne sont pas encore
vaccinés quels arguments reviennent
souvent les arguments je pense que le
fait de
on salue le gouvernement a beaucoup
patauger là dessus sur ceux sur la déjà
la constitution des vaccins là comme ça
tous tout au long de cette épidémie le
gouvernement tâtonne voilà je crois
qu'on est pas on n'est pas rassuré déjà
de la composition des vaccins et de
toute façon je crois que ça répond pas
aux problèmes de l'épidémie il n'y a pas
que les soignants qu'il faut qu'ils
doivent être vaccinés donc l'obligation
vaccinale si elles veulent être de toute
façon elle va avoir lieu l'obligation
vaccinale que je soit pour ou contre
l'obligation vaccinale le gouvernement
de toute façon va nous l'imposé et il
faut espérer l'ins pose aussi à la toute
la population française parce que que je
sois vacciner pas vacciner ça va pas
faire évoluer l'immunité collective de
notre pays c'est tout le monde tout le
monde doit être vacciné voilà si on veut
faire face à cette épidémie
il faut que tout le monde soit vacciné
et je pense que passer par une
obligation c'est quand même une atteinte
de nos libertés individuelles
je crois qu'on est quand même
responsable suffisamment responsable en
tant que soignantes et en tant qu'être
humain je suis suffisamment responsable
de ce qui se passait au courant de ce
qui se passe pour savoir si j'ai envie
de me faire vacciner ou pas forcément
envie d'être vaccinés merci je vous
comprends bien ce qui vous agace surtout
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que cette
vaccination obligatoire ne concerne ne
concernerait que les soignants puisque
vous venez de dire que finalement si
elle était obligatoire pour l'ensemble
de la population alors la donne sera un
peu différente mais la donne sera
différent et de toute façon il va
falloir qu'on en passe par là je crois
que le gouvernement veut nous obliger
obliger les soignants se faire soigner
laisser la porte d'entrée pour toute la
vaccination obligatoire en france sur
cette question de la tante liberticide
bruno m'égare ban qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire est ce que vous y répondez la
dimension collective c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette vaccination pourrait
être rendu obligatoire m'écouter au
contraire le fait d'être vacciné va
permettre à l'individu de gagner en
liberté d'abord il sera protégé et donc
il pourra
conduire un certain nombre d'activités
de loisirs de culture de rencontre en
toute sécurité
donc c'est une liberté pour lui même et
c'est surtout la liberté de ne pas nuire
voire de constituer une menace ou un
danger pour autrui
je crois que la liberté de chacun
s'arrête lorsque l'on menace ou met en
danger la liberté de l'autre et savoir
que l'on peut être à l'origine d'un
cluster ou être à l'origine de l'entrée
du virus dans une communauté de
personnes fragiles et donc d'être à
l'origine de décès éventuel de personnes
je crois tout personne bien consciente
ce d'autant plus que c'est une
professionnelle de santé qu'elle a
choisi ce travail est bien serait en
faveur de l'obligation vaccinale
je suis d'accord avec que votre
interlocutrice effectivement très
probablement on va se diriger d'ailleurs
pas que en france mais un peu partout
dans le monde vers une obligation de
vaccination car c'est le seul moyen pour
pouvoir permettre à l'ensemble de
l'humanité de passer ce cap épidémique
qui malheureusement depuis deux ans a
entraîné des millions de morts
est-ce pas si la vaccination chez les
soignants et compliquée du fait
peut-être
une logistique est ce que lorsque le
gouvernement annonce dédiée des centres
au fonctionnel à ce que cela aussi peut
créer un élan pour que david davantage
de personnel soignant aillent se faire
vacciner plus facilement plus rapidement
sur son lieu de travail est ce que c'est
déjà le cas peut-être aussi mais chaque
citoyen si les soignants avaient envie
de se faire vacciner il ya bien enfin
entre guillemets il ya bien lurette
qu'il aurait fait voilà y'a pas besoin
de créer des choses
enfin on y à tous accès très rapidement
à l'argument que ça soit un soignant ou
la population mais je crois que ça faut
pas nous faut pas parler que des
soignants je crois que on n'est pas les
premiers
on n'est pas les seuls en première ligne
que fait-on des caissières peu fait-on
des pompiers des ambulanciers
eux aussi sont enfin sont des gens qui
peuvent rencontrer des gens fragiles
dans les soigneurs voiles affalées seul
à aller au contact du public c'est ce
que vous nous dites ce bonhomme et
garden c'est l'obligation vaccinale
était confirmée demain soir par emmanuel
macron quelles devraient être les
sanctions qui l'accompagnent selon vous
alors tout d'abord effectivement le très
probablement le périmètre des personnes
qui devront se faire vacciner de par la
loi ne sera probablement pas réservé aux
strictement soignant mais à toutes les
pré free les professions qui sont en
rapport avec des personnes fragiles et à
risque alors je dirais pour ma part dans
un premier temps cette obligation on va
surtout en fait poussé les personnes qui
hésitent qui se posent encore des
questions qui attendent tout simplement
ne sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs mais qui
attendent en se disant l'épidémie pour
le moment est sous contrôle
eh bien ça va pousser ces personnes à se
vacciner et je crois que ceci représente
la quasi-totalité des soignants non
vaccinés encore à mon avis le noyau de
vaccinaux sceptiques dogmatique
idéologie par idéologie est extrêmement
réduit effectivement pour ces personnes
là il faudra envisager de changer de
poste
probablement pour un poste administratif
ou de logistique qui ne maintenant
danger les autres alors je n'espère pas
qu'on soit obligé d'en arriver à des
sanctions financières mais évidemment au
bout d'un certain temps chacun devra
prendre ses responsabilités vous
partager ce point de vue mais n'a vu
freine finalement aujourd'hui les
soignants qui ne sont encore pas
vacciner le font pas tellement pour des
raisons idéologiques
non non je pense pas de toute façon
sinon on serait pas soignants quoi faire
face faut être logique avec par rapport
aussi à notre profession quoi par contre
c'est vrai que je connais des soignants
et des médecins chefs de services qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
c'est pas la majorité des médecins et
yakin des médecins qui sont réticents
pareil comme disait monsieur qui attend
qu'ils attendent quoi je ne sais pas un
recul peut-être éventuel d'effets
secondaires dont on nous parle plus trop
encore que on sait quand même qu'il ya
des effets secondaires sur les vaccins
avec pardon l'injection du vaccin
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas voilà je s
qui lance la médecine et voilà par
contre moi ce que je trouve un petit peu
déplorable à l'heure actuelle donc
j'habite près de la frontière
il ya quand même des gens qui ont choisi
de ne pas se faire vacciner donc c'est
un choix c'est un respect de l'individu
mais par contre à l'heure actuelle je me
retrouve à faire attester des gens qui
veulent aller en espagne qui veulent
aller au restaurant qui veulent aller un
concert un moment donné je pense qu'il
faut prendre aussi ses responsabilités
si on refuse la vaccination
c'est un choix qui est respectable qui
entend bab
même si on est soignants et que voilà on
ne sait pas en ayant ce genre de
comportement pour arriver évidemment à
l'immunité collective mais je pense que
par rapport aux tests etc
je crois que ces gens là font aussi
parce qu'ils se posent la question de ça
ils utilisent le système de santé
français
parce que à l'heure actuelle les tests
sont pas payés je pense que le
gouvernement aussi devraient
s'interroger lapsus pour les gersois de
ne pas se faire vacciner
bruno m'égare banda aujourd'hui à
au-delà de la question très précise du
coût vite calé
obligation légale pour les soignants
maintien de vaccination alors nous avons
quatre vaccins obligatoires et il faut
savoir par exemple que la poliomyélite
est obligatoire alors même que
finalement la maladie a disparu de la
surface de la terre
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus un seul
patient qui est porteur de poliomyélite
donc on ne comprendrait pas pourquoi une
vaccination contre un agent infectieux
qui sévit partout et qui est aussi
menaçant ne devienne pas obligatoire
alors concernant la population générale
effectivement un temps donné et le
ministre de la santé l'a rappelé lorsque
tout le monde aura eu le temps de se
faire vacciner
s'ils souhaitent et bien à un moment
donné il faudra contraindre les
personnes qui ont décidé de ne pas se
faire vacciner et bien à payer les tests
qui seront utiles pour voyager ou
évidemment pour aller dans des concerts
mais également très bientôt dans tout
type d'activité car à mon sens le pass
sanitaire sera demandée y compris dans
les restaurants les cafés les théâtres
les cinémas les lieux de sport c'est il
faut savoir c'est par cette mesure que
l'état d'israël a réussi à vacciner en
masse sa population et on voit
aujourd'hui alors même que l'épidémie
rue circule sous forme de vapeur lta et
bien il n'y a aucun outil quasiment
aucun patient à l'hôpital et les décès
sont proches de ces bons atouts dernier
vous avec vos amis n'a dufrègne parce
qu'aujourd'hui la vaccination
obligatoire concerne n'aurait surtout
les soignantes qu'elle risquait ce qu'
elle pourrait engendrer sur
l'attractivité de ces métiers
l'attractivité déjà mise à mal
enfin j'entends quand même des collègues
enfin surtout par rapport à l'hôpital
public qui est déjà malheureusement le
parent pauvre
est un parent pauvre de la santé je
crois qu'il ya quand même beaucoup il ya
des soignants qui veulent en partir
et en plus si on les force à se vacciner
je pense qu'il y aura des départs de
l'hôpital public
à mon grand regret merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cet échange ce soir
mélina dufrègne la fléche l infirmière
membres des collectifs des soignants en
danger et bruno mais gardanne chef du
service réanimation à la piste à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris merci à
tous les deux et à bientôt sur rt france